sec ministre délégué chargé des
personnes handicapées merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés et Madame la Députée Servane
Hugues d'abord je vous remercie
sincèrement de mettre en lumière les
aidants dont le rôle est précieux dans
l'autre société
le 6 octobre dernier était la journée
des aidants et nous tenions ce jour-là
avec la première ministre le premier
comité interministériel du handicap de
ce gouvernement nous avons pu y entendre
la parole des aidants leur place est
évidemment essentielle mais souvent trop
méconnu ils sont encore nombreux à
ignorer le rôle qu'ils endossent et les
droits qu'il accompagne un tiers d'entre
eux délaisse leur propre santé
incarn n'arrive pas à se ménager de
répit alors oui le gouvernement est
mobilisé pour améliorer leur quotidien
alors oui beaucoup de progrès ont été
réalisés comme vous venez de le dire par
la stratégie nationale pour les aidants
qui vient de déployer et oui il ne faut
action accentuer nos efforts nous
élaborons avec le ministère des
solidarités Jean-Christophe combe et le
ministère de la Santé François Brown une
nouvelle stratégie baptisée agir avec
les aidants elle sera co-construite
comme toutes les stratégies que nous
mettons à neuves avec les premiers
concernés et donc de personnes en
situation de handicap de personnes âgées
mais aussi et aussi j'allais dire deux
personnes malades l'évolution de la
définition de procédant dans le code de
l'action sociale et des familles
permettra de prendre en compte
l'ensemble de ces situations des danses
la question du répit est majeure et elle
sera au coeur de cette stratégie je
tiens à rappeler l'engagement du
président de la République
soit de garantir deux semaines de répit
par an pour les aidants c'est un
engagement fort aujourd'hui
252 plateformes de répit ont été
déployés il nous faudra renforcer ces
solutions de répit en termes de maillage
territorial il faut qu'elle soit
présente partout sur le territoire de
notre pays ainsi que en termes de
diversité de l'offre merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin